so this is bad timing what the fuck
those are those things going on LSP what
else P episode what do you expect
Hey I mean okay well just go over the
straightforward episode it's an episode
where bubblegum creates this sort of
time bubble where you can travel back in
time ish
I mean you don't time itself doesn't
change just you kind of not do yeah you
changed but the world itself does not
like your memory and your actions kind
of change but what you affect does it
depending on what you do anyway it's
this time bubble and LSP meets someone
and she falls in love and he's really
nice but then of course she gets really
really jealous again thinking that's
gonna go after someone else go after
bubblegum and she tries to send him back
in time before meeting bubblegum but
he's sent to a place where we don't know
and because she did it wrong and then
she has bubblegum to swap the bubble on
and get rid of her memory of it and she
does that and bubblegum has a drink
so it's about the episode but it's not
the whole thing the whole episode is
done in this this iris is black circle
and except the black circle fills up
with all these little you know shapes
and characters running around some blow
balloon and then the balloon gets popped
there's some dig a hole and they pop out
the other end and once a peanut that
opens up and two little nuts pop out
then the shell gets back together makes
a new kind of peanut pretty all these
old things are happening and you know I
can't talk that much about the episode
cuz I was mostly watching that I was
like what what is this building up to
what is this leading to I'm thinking
like maybe bubblegum is watching this
all through a microscope and these are
like little amoebas Wow
looking at so I didn't know I had no
idea but it never tells us what it is
what's this another April Fool's no no
no you two kind of learned what it is
dude do I I okay those things that she
sent back in time in the opening they
kind of looked like those yeah but but
why were they through the whole episode
why was it in the iris and everything I
didn't get it cuz that was the bubble
if that's the bubble then why are those
things outside the bubble and why are we
seeing all that you know that is the
bubble the outside borders the bubble so
they're watching it through the bubble
kind of yeah
why planet why so
exactly Naruto what was he chasing bug
or something yeah he's gonna give his
claws cut in there okay it's trying to
he's attacking the curtains no cuz if
you notice what you I'm guessing you
didn't who shows up in there uh oh did
uh the boyfriend show yeah I first his
head shows up then his body shows up
then it's - he's chasing around his body
and then they form in to each other they
get how did I miss that part like I've
been watching although the cartoon
network logo covered a lot of it uh yeah
over the bottom right side no it's on
the left is on the left side but on the
Left okay uh and yeah I totally miss
Aysen okay so that makes a little bit
more sense okay so he's he's in
somewhere he's probably in those little
with those little creatures or whatever
yeah possibly
um alright so it's just showing where he
is at least now we know where he is um
digs and first just makes his head
disappear ya know and then puts it back
oh wait you take it to the point where
you yeah I'm especially go on I mean it
was it was kind of intriguing I mean
like I said it'll start hypnotizing you
know watching them but at the same time
I was like you know what is what is
going on I I don't get you know it's me
did happen after she got rid of the head
in the body yeah see she goes back to
the bar and bottom left alone okay
we're just looking at this real fast but
I mean if they were there any oh you're
right yeah now I see him and then
there's the body well there it is yeah I
you know of
of course it's the one time like I was
focusing on the actual episode at the
variant oh that's it he wants to be back
in there oh hey he wants to see he wants
to be with her yeah and he puts his head
down he disappear well okay that's
that's sad
the one time lumpy Space Princess
actually has something good and her
stupidity destroys it yeah
let's also talk about that for one she's
all doing this nice speech it's just
like I don't know if I can what's a
Molotov cocktail just throws it in the
window and then the truck goes in and
then bubblegum tells him there's society
he's sucking that gum under yeah I'm
just adding to her very dark dark way no
that's that's what you're supposed to do
every proper military person well most
other countries that's what you need
yeah like the cyanide pills and stuff
but she's not Bella Terry she's royalty
I don't know that's the same it is
pretty much she Brian does a lot of our
stuff royalty aren't supposed to do yeah
she does a lot of probably like human
being she's not a human being yeah okay
fair enough
um but she does a lot of things kandi is
not supposed to do kandi is not supposed
to kill people I'm sorry or robot or
upper Canady yeah I guess it is just
other can be the more I think about em
robots but um okay so now that I know
that that makes it a little better
cuz I totally was missing that um but if
you miss that it's very small and like
if you do kind of blink or not pay
attention you don't kind of notice it
which kind of it's extra if you pay
attention but at the same time if you
don't you kind of lose it and you can
look at it as well like episodes kind of
just in yeah it's um even if you do see
it I mean it's something where it's like
okay it's a little clever to see answer
materialize somewhere else and I I
applaud the ambition to want to do
something where there's something going
on throughout the whole episode you're
not sure what it is and it's on the
border and I was actually like grilling
treat them like where is this going like
and I wasn't annoyed watching it either
sort of like you know no IDs things are
kind of neat walking around and like I
said it's almost kind of hypnotic yeah
you know and if they move very slowly
and they weren't like they weren't too
distracting like you know you could
still follow the episode okay so I was I
was actually kind of digging it um and
that I think that that's not a bad
ending where he pops up in the middle of
yet has to chase the body that looks an
area you know but it's I wish it was a
little bit more I don't either the story
connected better to it or there is a
stronger payoff oh I think he's four I
think he's forever trapped in the bubble
yeah that's what I'm thinking too it's
just wherever that is a some sort of
world where you're just looking through
this bubble yes all the other things
slowly fade away yeah they're they're
very dim when they enter and they're
very you know then they slowly fade away
he shows up he's very solid and he
doesn't he has never fade away mm-hmm
remember the first two that she does so
it all goes black
well yeah but I think that's also end of
episode nobody goes black before the
episode ends and it was also blank
before I started to eye even the time of
card was in the black and the glimmer at
least um obviously he's forever trapped
there
probably I mean it's since he wasn't
backed up as they say I mean it's it's
one of those things where it's like
again I kind of I like sort of the
tragic element to it you know I sort of
like that I just it's it's a tough one
because if the story was a little
stronger and really supported it like
that the character is okay he's not bad
character yeah you know but he's not
like super memorable or you know like I
don't remember his name but that's
nothing new for me um and I know for
something that was so built up I was
hoping like I said just something of a
stronger payoff but now that I know that
that does help yeah that does help me
appreciate it a little bit more and it's
like oh it's like another dimension
another wherever looking outside of this
bubble I'm just guessing oh that's not
even like what I've seen that's better
I'm just guessing well no just that we
know he's transported to you know an
area that's not there and you can see
through it and stuff I mean we don't
know
it is but we if it didn't connect to the
episode at all that I serve be like what
the hell but the fact you see
materialize there's like okay it does
connect it does the appellees connect um
so it'll be interesting if that if that
leads to something like in another
episode you do see all these things were
part of another world or something or
something else watching other worlds I
mean that should be fun I mean then be a
great build up to it I mean that is one
of the great things about the show is
that you can do that you know you can
just bring something back that maybe
didn't think of before or like didn't
make sense before but now it does um so
I like to see that because actually it
I'd like to see Finn and Jake get
scanned into it and then they'd like
journey around or something I show up
that I'd be kind of cool actually or
maybe like maybe they're there and then
like you know how you heard them in the
circle
maybe instead you hear Finn and Jake in
in the other ends of the circle and you
don't hear what's actually inside the
circle so they're constantly talking and
trying to find way it do that I'll wait
to find a way communicate or something
it's like that that can be kind of fun
yeah that'd be edgy I really need
episodes so it's like in a strange way
it's like I can see it's as good
build-up to another episode but on its
own O's is kind of a yeah it's like if
you got rid of that and you only watch
the episode itself it's not bad
interesting yeah and if you look at the
outer rims you know it's it's a neat
idea and I can see it going so where
like I would live if they brought it
back and did even more with it no so
like you didn't focus on LSP yeah like I
said if you did something where like you
said Finn and Jake are in there and
trying to get back and they're trying to
talk to the inner circle or they
interact more or something yeah uh I
think that can be kind of fun if this
was just a build-up to an episode where
they're going to do it better and then
I'd give a pass you know but this is
like the only time they're ever gonna do
that I'd be like there's a cool
opportunity here you know like come on
let's really take advantage of it um I
said cuz the show is so good at taking
advantage of its opportunity that's you
know and of its world and its characters
and stuff and they even an episode where
we're like you know yeah that wasn't so
hot or whatever it's like they still
like whatever
eighty or ninety percent but I take
advantage of what they have and what
they can do
my most disliked episode like I did not
like glitches glitch as everyone knows
but even like with my most disliked
episode it's still entertaining to an
extent to watch they do take advantage
of what they possibly can there's very
few episodes I there's none I can think
of off the top of my head where I'm like
now I'd never watched that ever again
like even a glitch is a glitch I would
be willing to go back and rewatch it
again easily each one has something
something creative something new in it
yeah and like this is one of those where
if it wasn't for that outer rim I would
have probably been like wow terrible
episode but that ring helped create
something different something Newton I
almost got wonder if they did this story
you know a story pour it in everything
and then just at the very end they're
like no no it feels like they we need
something else and maybe they just
thought of that at the very end it's a
good show maybe we just see this world
going on around and then at the end he
pops up that nobody will know life there
until he pops up and now he's just there
and it's like this big weird and joke or
something um so I mean I can see it
throwing in at the very end but it's
like whatever the reason they put it in
there it's like I like I said even
though this one I thought was mad it's
like I wouldn't mind seeing another one
where they explore it even more and they
have even more fun with what they can do
with it yeah that would be interesting
yeah so um yeah hopefully though
hopefully we'll see another one with it
and they'll do even more stuff with it
but if not yeah it could have been a lot
stronger code a lot more of it I did
like but dislike the way that Jake was
like entirely time travel Phoebe's
getting all upset Ice King did it better
dude you're being a jerk but you're
funny I like how it's like he's kind of
right I mean it's like it's not really
it's untrue it kind of is but it kind of
misses like time travel is like you know
literally time itself goes backwards
here it's just like the people so going
backwards
it can't be forwards what about the time
itself well I guess it's my travel it is
the per
travelin man but that's well that's kind
of the thing whatever is in this bubble
is changing its time well everything
else around it is not yeah I guess so
later think about she did what she did
with LSP hmm
LSP winterly traveled back in time to
where she was before all this happened
hmm that is time travel she had no
recollection or anything that happened
after that I always loved those ones
where it's like they travel in time but
like they're in the middle of space it's
like yeah well the Earth rotates point
in time where they halfway through
someone else know that somebody did then
I can't remember what but they were like
floating in space and like oh like
whatever they make another wish or
something or they time travel somewhere
back where they were ass like yeah the
Earth rotates you know no that's that's
one thing I'd love to see like you
teleport in or you time travel back in
your hands like halfway through a thing
of pop that would be funny to me
suffering people make me laugh
especially time soon let's let's make
that happen our sick disgusting time
travel story and we'll have an outer rim
of you know things going on and his name
was Brad Brad was the boyfriend that she
yes at let wanted so what's this guy's
name what was his name
you're asking me Johnny Johnny Johnny
Dunham finally Johnny oh yes that's
right buddy listen I'll gladly Mar ha ha
ha that's my LSP imprison ation I know a
woman does the voice so I'm not gonna
Pendleton or that was the joke you asked
who's that you know but that's that's
the joke Oh
that's wave our hands are a little bit
more what are you calling Pendleton ward
a girl you clearly don't get the joke
I'm not gonna explain to you cuz there's
no Jo there's a joke where's the
punchline don't just punch me is that be
a stupid joke as well it also be a
stupid ending